je ne peux pas croire qu'en dehors de
bien ce tunnel si tu es d'accord avec
moi quand je ne suis pas là elle est
l école
ton partenaire ou sa partenaire et que
fidèle alors ça je sais c'est
senna senna gauche la hâte en quelle
et tout le monde est bien la presse tu
vivant à
auras sur une époque je te rassure
année attends je me gratte à n'ya que
caroline la majorité des couples en
moi si je ne peux pas croire que fatou
france surtout les couples hétéros ils
isabelle alonso mais la saisie des armes
soit là yvan attal pour charlotte
sont classiques fidèles avec une vie
avant mais après j'ai pas eu le temps
gainsbourg absolument
autonome et hafid banques et à vous
d'abord nommé avant 5 ou trompeuses et
allez petit tour de table un juste comme
pas non mais la cérémonie de mariage
ça parce que vous avez tous été j'avais
mois quand le prêtre a dit j'aurais vous
aller aux états unis vous savez à la
tous et c'est en couple ou marié qui n'a
fidélité j'ai dit faut voir
jamais trompé à moi jamais je n'ai
mort de la fille de jane birkin elle est
et elle est le copain d'une nuit c'est
partie aux états unis il a dit en fait
jamais trop sans super méga fidèles
elle fait ce qu'elle veut je peux pas
alors le florian
le compagnon d'une vie et de quoi mais
croire qu'en dehors de moi quand je suis
pas là les fidèles je ne veux rien
quand j'ai pas envie j'ai dit fais ce
que tu veux moi je dors mai
savoir si elle rentre c'est que je vaux
avant il ya la banque whaou à bon compte
le coup mais vous savez quoi c'est beau
et c'est tellement fou je pas pensé le
et
étudiants tout le monde le message comme
quotidien évoque le quotidien et like
qui n'est plus en danger le reste c'est
comment vous dire ccc d'un gendarme à
new york le reste bang bang bang bang
c'est rien c'est de la tôle s'est fait
passer des messages plus rien c'est de
la com non mais où est ce que je vais
dire donc ils sont coupables c'est ça
alors il sait pas ce qui est dit prêt ça
sinon on est dit je veux pas savoir
voilà voilà en tout cas c'est quelque
chose qu'il a toujours évoqué dans les
interviews l'est d'ailleurs c'est un
film il ya vingt ans en 2001 qui
s'appelait ma femme est une actrice dans
lequel il évoquait déjà le problème de
façon très sérieuse dans tout au tout
dit dans sa qui interviewe
[Musique]
être beaucoup plus discrète sur la
question c'est à dire qu'elle se répande
beaucoup moins dégagée de parler de ça
lui par contre tu sens que ça le titille
un peu et qu'on publie 30 ans avec
quelqu'un mais c'est lui que celle 8760
mai mais ses nus et ses deux béquilles
qui a décrété un jour je ne sais pas
c'est un truc cateau tiens vous savez
permettre à deux personnes à ces avis
château ceccato ou excuser de la plus
belle définition du mariage que c'est la
plus belle définition du couple mais le
couple est ce que m 2 personnes dans un
contrat point barre ce qu'il est si
dense oui
c'était une vraie relation avec vous
parce que si sincèrement on peut aller
baiser à droite à gauche se tromper et
surtout en plus faire bizarre le truc
genre j'ai pas vu je ne veux pas voir
c'est très simple d'être en couple avec
vous parce que toute la difficulté c'est
justement de se dire il faut que je
continue d'être désiré de désiré mon mec
etc si j'ai le dos tourné et qu' ils se
tapent quelqu'un mais comme l'a dit
mathieu emphatique et son contrat c'est
à dire que c'est avec sa partenaire ou
[Applaudissements]